en attendant le choix de la ville
organisatrice pour les jo de 2024 la
promotion passe par paris mais aussi
dans les yvelines
ce 21 février c'est au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin que les
différents sites retenus pour accueillir
les épreuves ont été présentés ce n'est
pas seulement paris c'est toute la
france qui souhaite qu'ils souhaitent
avoir légion et je crois que le cyclisme
sa partie prenante et nécessaire à la
contribution qu'elle doit apporter
vis-à-vis du sport en général et nous
nous battons donc aux côtés du comité
national olympique et sportif français
pour qu'ils aient justement ces jo
quatre sites sont au coeur du dispositif
dans les yvelines à versailles notamment
pour les épreuves équestres
le vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux la colline d'elancourt mais
aussi au golf national à guyancourt
c'est très très important puisque nous
avons un sport qui est toujours
considéré comme un peu à la fois
élitiste et confidentiel le fait qu'ils
soient revenues dans les jeux olympiques
montre que c'est un sport qui peut se
démocratiser pour toucher le plus grand
nombre de personnes évidemment nous
soutenons la candidature de paris aux
jeux puisque nous avons des
infrastructures qui nous permettent
d'accueillir cette belle épreuve des
expositions seront installés pour
valoriser les bills yvelinoise et des
actions de communication seront établis
dès le mois de mars avec un seul
objectif mettre toutes les chances du
côté de paris